-Welcome back, everybody. We are
talking to Senator Cory Booker
The President names you
specifically and says
you are trying to destroy
the American dream by supporting
affordable housing
in the suburbs.
You grew up in the suburbs
Can you speak to the sort of
blatant racism behind this
both where he stands on
the issue and why he keeps
bringing your name into it
-Look, as one of my close
friends said to me,
the fact that the Presiden
brought you up multiple time
in tweets and rallies
should be a sign
that you're actually
doing something.
But speaking to him
is not what --
frankly, if I can
answer your question more
by speaking to us, as a country,
we are this phenomenal natio
with reservoirs of love an
decency that are always ther
but we don't always
draw down upon them.
And this is a president who ha
so, I think -- been such poiso
to the spirit and the energy
that's in our country.
And I know of no other way
to do that than to reject it
And not to reject it with
just, like, more bile.
I still remember,
in one of my town halls
when I was running for
president, a guy comes up to m
and says, "Dude, I want you to
punch Donald Trump in the face."
And I looked at him
and I laughed.
And I said,
"Dude, that's a felony."
We cannot beat that energy b
bringing more of that energy
That's what he wants.
He wants us to get down
and fight in the gutter
and in a way
that none of us win.
This is a time when we see
his kind of racism and bigotry
We see his blatant
fearmongering,
trying to prey upon the
insecurities or latent strains
of negativity in our society
We have to reject it
and reject him.
I don't care what your party is.
Both parties,
Republicans and Democrats,
we're better than this.
We should be calling peopl
to the best of our angels,
the highest of our aspirations
to the best of our virtues
and not what he does
on a regular basis,
which is demonstrate vile,
dehumanizing, debasing behavior.
It's just wrong
and, God, I just --
I don't want to
just win this election
for some kind of
partisan reason.
I want this to be a national
rejection of Trumpism,
of all that he has brought
into our public spaces.
And I want us to see,
at the end of this election,
not just one candidate
being elevated but all of us
committing ourselves
to having a revival
in this country of civic grace
-You had some spirited moments
with former Vice President Biden
during the Democratic debate
but some amicable moments
during the commercial breaks
Is that right?
-Yeah.
I have to say, I knew Joe Biden.
He swore me into the job
that I had.
But I really got to know him i
the way you do with, you know,
the rival kids you played with
in high school, for example.
And I am just a big believer
that contests like that
don't build character,
they reveal it.
And by the end of the campaign
I was thoroughly disarmed by him
and admired him.
And I remember a tough moment.
He had said something
that I found offensive.
And I still remember,
I was on a major news network,
talking about it from my heart
and speaking about
why it was so hurtful to me.
And then something
that has never happened to m
before in public life --
I got off that station
and I get a phone call
from Joe Biden.
And he doesn't call me.
It's not one of these puffery,
political-speak kind of calls.
He called me
with a sense of vulnerabilit
and saying to me, really, that
he doesn't always get it right
and that he is still learnin
and he is still growing
and he really
wanted to understand.
And, you know,
Trump has this way of
never being wrong,
never apologizing.
Biden has this way of saying
"You know what?
None of us are beyond sticking
our foot in our mouth,
making mistakes.
But maybe, if we own up to them,
we can all learn together,
all grow together,
and heal together."
And so,
by the end of the campaign
I considered him a friend
and someone that I admired
and now someone I very muc
want, especially at this tim
where we need healing,
I want him to be my president.
-I asked your colleague Senato
Klobuchar this on Monday.
What are your plans
for election night?
Where are you going to watch it?
How you going to feel?
-So, my hope is just to be
relaxed while sitting next t
Rosario on a couch somewhere
and eating junk food vegan
And, God willing, watching
an election that I hope --
we should all
have the expectation
that it won't be
decided that night.
But I have a lot of hope
that night
that there'll be
a lot to celebrate.
And also, you know, the Senate
I mean, Mitch McConnell, who
calls himself the Grim Reaper,
I'm really hoping that from Iowa
to Texas to South Carolina
that we win a lot of Senat
seats that people didn't expect.
Surprise a lot of people
and give a further repudiation
of Trumpism.
-Alright. All the best to you.
Thank you so much for making
time for us, Senator.
Really appreciate it.
-Hey.
I just want to tell you
something because
a lot of times, people think o
entertainment or art
as entertainment.
And I just want to let you kno
that during this time of Trump
you've just been one of
those folks that I think
has given a master class
in showing that satire
is essential to a democracy,
the ability not only to
criticize power but, really,
call it into question in a way
that stimulates people's
understanding and action.
Art is essential to a democracy,
especially in a time of trial.
And you've just done a wonderful
job and have given me
not only a lot of laughter but
even sustained and nurtured me
and nourished me in a time tha
I really needed it.
-I'm so glad you said that
in front of my crew,
who do not respect me at all
[ Laughter ]